(thunder strike)
(banjo music)
- What do you think of
when you hear the word, 'banjo'?
Maybe you think of an iconic Muppet frog
strumming the first notes
of "Rainbow Connection,"
or even footage of a certain 1970s comic
using it with his routine.
The banjo was at one time
the most popular instrument in America
with tens of thousands
manufactured and sold
between 1910 and 1930 alone.
It's been called America's instrument.
But how it became a Bluegrass staple
started in a place many don't know about.
I flew out to Nashville
to meet some of the
best banjo players in the world,
and hopefully I can talk one of them
into giving me a banjo lesson.
- Well, there's not much to it.
♪ Baby shark, do do do do do do ♪
♪ Baby shark do do do do do do ♪
♪ Baby shark ♪
♪ Mama ♪
Oh come on, Dante.
You know it.
♪ I was born unto this earth ♪
♪ Green grasses softened my birth ♪
♪ Blue heaven shuttered me deep ♪
♪ Beneath an evergreen sky ♪
♪ I withdrew from the light of the sun ♪
- We want to know more about the banjo
as an instrument, the history behind it,
just all things about the banjo.
'Cause we think that the banjo
deserves a little more attention.
- Agreed.
- Agreed, yeah.
♪ She was a rose ♪
♪ A blooming rose ♪
- [Nahre] Bela Fleck and Abigail Washburn
both play banjo.
Correction, they are both banjo masters.
(banjo strums)
Bela has been dubbed the
world's premier banjo player
and has performed solo and
with his band The Flecktones.
His unique sound called Blu-bop,
a mix of bluegrass and jazz
has led to him winning fourteen Grammy's.
♪ At first it was only a trace ♪
♪ And the beauty quickened its pace ♪
- [Nahre] Abigail, a
Grammy winner as well,
performs as a soloist
and with old time bands
to international acclaim.
She works different cultures
into her performances.
She also performs with
her husband, Bela Fleck.
♪ And the towers rise up on the bough ♪
♪ 'Till there is nothing left we can do ♪
- [Nahre] Abigail and Bela
play very distinctive styles.
While their instruments
look similar to one another,
a closer look at their hands shows
how they create very different sounds.
A typical bluegrass style
is three finger picking,
using picks on the thumb,
index, and middle fingers.
It's almost like you need
three hands to do it.
(rapid banjo strumming)
- So, in other words, with a flat pick
you'd hit the same string
over and over again.
Like up and down.
(banjo strums)
But with these...
(rapid banjo strumming)
- This is like a roll that's just going
straight along.
So we're playing 16th notes.
We're playing 1 e & a 2 e & a.
Now, here's the fun part.
When you do a forward
roll, which is like this.
(banjo strums)
So see I'm going
a 1 e & a 2 e & a 3 e & a 4 e & a.
You see I'm playing 16th note but look,
I'm doing it with three fingers.
- [Nahre] It goes from one to two.
- One has to come up
on a different finger,
like one, two, three, four.
One, two, three, four.
So the rhythm, you kinda have to feel that
rhythm as you're going along.
When you get that feel for it
then you can make it happen.
- So try this, can you do this?
(banjo strums)
So this is the tricky thing that
the highest string is
next to the lowest string.
It's not where you expect
it in your mind to be.
Okay, now try this real slow
(banjo strums)
Great.
That's it.
Now repeat those for an hour and a half.
- So, now Nahre, you're going
to learn the better form of banjo playing.
- Okay.
- Just in case you were wondering.
- [Nahre] Another style is clawhammer
using the finger nails to
brush across the strings
as the thumb drops and picks
directly on the strings.
- It's really like a strike of one string
with either your pointer
or your middle finger.
And then a brush, and then a
pull off on the drone string,
and that's good and all.
But I got excited about
some other kinds of playing.
One piece of clawhammer frailing
is that you can actually
drop your thumb down.
So, this is another...
(banjo strums)
(banjo strums rapidly)
So that's just striking down.
So he's pulling up with his picks,
with his metal picks.
And I'm striking down
with my finger nails.
(banjo strums)
Do that for an hour and a half.
(laughing)
- An hour and a half.
- Oh, this is pretty good,
when he was courting me
he tried to learn my
style of banjo playing.
It was funny.
- I wasn't very good.
- We can see how one instrument
proves to be a facet of sounds.
But where did these sounds originate?
While it's been called
a America's instrument
the banjo's ancestry like
most of American culture
can actually be traced to
many different countries.
Drum-like instruments with strings
are recorded in the history of several
far East, Middle Eastern, Mediterranean,
and African civilizations.
This idea of the banjo was brought
to America from the enslaved Africans
in the 17th Century.
These early banjos were often made
out of gourds, wood, turtle shells,
or tree trunks with tanned
animal skin wrapped over them.
- When Bela went to Africa it
was really exciting for me.
I saw his documentary afterwards.
And he was in the Gambia
and playing with a family
called the Jatta family.
And they have these instruments
called the akonting.
They're three string.
And they're basically this banjo,
but they're three string
and they're made with gourd.
And the way they played just looks
exactly the way I play.
It just looks exactly like it.
- [Bela] The right hand
is exactly the same.
- Yeah.
- In the early years of
its American evolution,
the banjo would be
considered a folk instrument
played mostly by and for enslaved people.
By the mid-1800s, the banjo gained
international popularity
with traveling minstrels.
A racist and demeaning
form of entertainment
where white performers
dressed in black face,
and often used the banjo.
Recreating a distorted
view of slavery in America
as a care-free, happy existence.
One of those minstrel players
was Joel Walker Sweeney.
Credited with popularizing
the five string banjo,
Sweeney contracted a
drum maker in Baltimore,
William Boucher Jr.
to manufacture banjos for public sale.
Boucher's introduction
of metal-tuning brackets
to tighten the head was incorporated into
what is known as the "Boucher Banjo."
This was a major step
in the banjo's journey
from being a home-made, folk creation
to the instrument we see today.
(banjo strums)
- I have made, since 2000, we've done
about 18 hundred and 25 banjos
so far, that I've built.
(banjo strums)
So a banjo's basically auto parts.
That's what I like.
- Auto parts?
- Yeah, not really, but
you know what I mean.
It's metal, okay?
A guitar is mainly it's all wood.
(banjo music)
A banjo you can take apart.
So you've gotta to imagine about
75 parts to a banjo if you're
counting every little tiny
thing, or something like that.
On a guitar, mandolin,
you're forming the wood.
You're gluing the braces.
You're gluing the neck, and
you're gluing the bridge on.
You really can't take that apart.
So, completely different.
That's why I like to say it's auto parts.
And you can change the
thickness of that head,
and get a completely different sound.
The only other instrument
that uses that is a drum.
Right?
So a banjo's basically a
drum with a neck on it.
Hey, how'd you like that?
- Beautiful!
By the end of the Civil War the
banjo spread across players of all
different kinds of backgrounds.
After the Civil War, the banjo was
considered legitimatized and
used for classical performance,
as well as a new popular sound, ragtime.
(ragtime music)
- [Steve] It used to be
the turn of the century
there were these five string,
they were actually five string banjos.
The guys were playing
classical music on them,
the most gorgeous music.
And they say up in Boston,
there was a banjo on every corner.
- The banjo was it in America.
Banjo players were just as
popular as today's pop stars.
But then the Great Depression hit.
(instrumental music)
By 1940, for practical
purposes the banjo was dead.
Guitars sold for one-third
of the price of a banjo,
and thus, took its place
as big band music took off.
I'd love to hear
anything, done by you two.
- Okay, we've got a tune
that we've been working on.
(banjo music)
- [Nahre] Five string folk banjo
was bubbling behind the scenes
in Appalachia and the Ozarks.
Artists like Pete Seeger introduced
the instrument to the masses
as the folk boom launched.
(slow banjo music)
This was also known as the folk scare,
for political stances taken by several
musicians viewed as rebels.
And a new identity was solidified
in the banjo as artists
like, Earl Scruggs,
popularized the three finger picking style
that re-defined the instrument.
(lively banjo music)
- Bela Fleck said it, he said,
"We all wanted to sound like Earl."
- By the 1960s and 70s
the banjo was locked in
with country and bluegrass music.
(banjo music)
So do you think it's just a matter of,
more people being exposed to the banjo
for them to gravitate
towards it as an instrument?
- Absolutely.
There used to be this paradigm
about banjos just kind of,
country, hay bales kind of thing.
But that's gone.
(banjo music)
So my theory is
players like Bela,
they're aliens.
Mark my words, they're aliens.
It's true.
Aliens are here.
(banjo music)
- [Nahre] Today, banjo
has had another rebirth.
With bands like Trampled by Turtles,
and Mumford and Sons,
bringing the sound to new audiences.
(lively banjo music)
- I've seen a change in
bluegrass music, recently.
A lot of younger folks getting into it.
They're playing for two years, right?
And they're six times better than I was
when I was playing for eight years.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
- But they can't make a banjo like you.
- They probably can if they want to.
(laughing)
- I wouldn't put it past them.
(melodic banjo music)
- I'm Dante Limon.
I've been playing the banjo for
a little over a year.
- [Nahre] What's your favorite
thing about the banjo?
- Well, the way it sounds, I guess.
And how much fun it is to play it.
- [Nahre] The instrument can be heard in
different genres from folk to pop.
But then there's Rhiannon Giddens,
who returns to the real
origins of the instrument.
Playing a Boucher-style banjo,
and sharing her beautiful, modern takes
on music from those early humble days.
♪ A little bird, it strikes you now ♪
♪ Through the shiver and shaking blue ♪
♪ Don't know where I'm going, but ♪
♪ I know what to do ♪
(rhythmic soul music)
- There is a bigger banjo.
(banjo strums)
(banjo music)
♪ One foot forward, and one foot back ♪
♪ 20 time you've fall off the track ♪
- It's got a sound no instrument
in the orchestra can make.
And the banjo is one of those.
It doesn't sound like a guitar.
It does not sound like a mandolin.
It doesn't sound like a cello.
It doesn't sound like anything else.
And it's been fun to see
the change in my time
from being almost ostracized
for being a banjo player.
But even in Nashville, which you think,
"Oh, country music."
I moved to Nashville from New York
'cause there was some of a
bluegrass and a country scene,
And, "Oh, banjo's too country to have
"on country records anymore."
So in the 80s it was a stigma,
and you couldn't really
work as a banjo player.
It would be very rare.
The banjo was always the problem.
"Oh, you'll never make it
with that banjo in there.
"Bela should play guitar.
"Or you guys should get drums."
But, what's happened since then
to now is people are putting banjo
on to things to give it legitimacy,
where it used to be--
- Authenticity, yeah.
- Yeah.
- A different kind of sound that--
- Now you see it on rock records
and indie records.
- Like the indie, alt-pop, folk scene
that came along and got pretty excited
about the banjo, offering a different
kind of sound and aura.
♪ Bring it down ♪
♪ Don't let it bring you down ♪
- [Nahre] Time will show us
where the banjo goes next.
♪ Don't let it bring you down ♪
- [Nahre] One thing is certain,
it's definitely still alive, and ringing.
- How are you doing?
(banjo strums)
- [Nahre] Song writer Harlan Howard
has said that, "Country music is
"three chords and the truth."
Get to know the amazing music and artist
behind this uniquely American sound
in Ken Burns' new eight part documentary,
"Country Music."
Tune in or stream the series starting
on Sunday, September 15th.
(sweeping electronic music)